hey do you guys want to come grab food
with the big group of people terrified
of eating alone hey I'm your roommate
please don't be lame as [ __ ] we're gonna
be best friends until we find people we
actually have something in common with
oh I care way more about getting [ __ ]
up than going to class I'm trying really
hard to seem cooler than I was in high
school it's not working
my studies room is way cuter than yours
I was gonna smoke weed Oh what I'm
politely offering to switch beds with
you although we both know I'm not gonna
do it oh I'll do anything I can to avoid
confrontation we're gonna be sending an
unfortunate amount of time together hey
our parents already left so we're acting
like hot [ __ ] come on Oh once we start
rushing frats I'll definitely stop
hanging out with you I'm only being nice
to you because you have a fake ID this
is my first time away from home and I'm
actually terrified I checked you out on
Facebook and your sister is really hot I
will hit on her when she visits I'm
trying to sleep with every girl I meet
this week we're gonna hook up once and
then we'll avoid eye contact for the
next four years I am never gonna clean
this comforter
maybe if I puke on it but probably still
not this is my boyfriend we're gonna sex
I'll you all the time I'm gonna resent
the [ __ ] out of that I'll never tell you
when something's bothering me but I will
be extremely passive-aggressive about it
hooking up with you will be the first
mistake I make in college but definitely
not the last
this room's kind of miserable but I'm 18
and absolutely anything is better than
living with my parents
Allman scholarship so I'm only paying 20
grand to get [ __ ] up remember what I
look like now cuz I'm gonna gain 15
pounds I'm gonna bring back a ton of
Front boys and I don't really care if
you're in here I'll pretend to be
sleeping and hate every second of it
also I'm a huge NSYNC fan no strings
attached changed my life
hey I'm gonna pursue you sexually